dans ce dossier vous êtes invités à
juger l'europe sur le banc des accusés
déception les dix ans son rejet pour
certains ennuis désintérêt pour d'autres
depuis 60 ans elle fait débat un débat
qui a inspiré la compagnie les têtes de
l'art je voulais écriteau après les
dernières élections européennes de 2014
tout simplement je me suis posé une
question très simple c'est je suis
consterné par les résultats de la
dernière élection
qu'est-ce que moi en tant que citoyen et
en tant que directeur d'une structure
artistique et culturelle qu'est ce que
je peux faire sur ce sujet là et en fait
je ne suis pas expert qui ne fut pas
associations qui travaillent sur les
questions européennes je ne suis pas élu
politique mais par contre mes armes
c'est l'art inspiré par desproges et son
tribunal des flagrants délires l'europe
à la barre mêle fiction et réalité avec
une procureure un avocat de la défense
et un juge pragmatique en prenant le
public pour témoins moi c'est le point
de vue des citoyens que je défends et
donc l'europe a de très beaux projets
généralement à dont il n'est pas
question de savoir si si si l'europe
doit être ou ne pas être elle est là par
contre qui elle défend qui elle protège
est ce qu'on y prend parce qu'on n'y
comprend quelque chose livret de lyon ou
en tant que citoyen
les incohérences parfois entre ses
fondements
le fantasme européen est ce qui se passe
dans la réalité une élection avant
l'heure mais pour nous l'enjeu ils
étaient entre hal et ça c'est très
important c'est que pour nous l'enjeu
c'est de faire poser des questions aux
gens et de pas donné de réponse on passe
notre temps à écouter des réponses sur
l'europe ce qu'elle doit être que doit
pas être
nous ce qu'on veut c'est réinterroger
sur l'europe et les gens seraient
intéressés ce sujet un procès pour mieux
défendre cette europe à quelques
semaines du scrutin européen
la représentation était organisée par la
maison de l'europe des yvelines
[Musique]